bonjour marie soleil merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france ce matin
en direct qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
de ce rendez-vous castex von der leyen
aujourd'hui au sujet de la législation
sur les contenus et deux sur internet
est ce que paris et bruxelles peuvent
sur ce thème devrait d'un commun accord
on a déjà et depuis quelques mois une
consultation qui a été lancé au niveau
européen qui est une consultation le
digital services act qui a pour but en
toute hypothèse de réformer et un régime
qui est assez ancien puisque la
responsabilité sur internet c'est une
directive de 2000 ça n'a pas changé
depuis et on est toujours aujourd'hui
dans ce cadre et ses travaux la
commission européenne n'a pas attendu
qu'il y ait ce drame ses travaux avaient
déjà été engagés
est ce qu'on souhaite ou non régulés la
communication sur internet et notamment
les réseaux sociaux
c'est l'objet des travaux actuels avec
normalement un nouveau régime qui
devrait se dessiner pour la fin de
l'année le début de l'année prochaine
comment limiter concrètement la haine
sur internet sans empiéter sur la
liberté d'expression
alors pour limiter fin effectivement le
l'enjeu et ça a été dans le jeu
d'ailleurs de la loi vient et c'est pour
ça que la loi avia a été retoqué on
souhaite maintenir la liberté
d'expression la loi via elle avait ce
défaut qui était un système très
automatique ou si la scion notifier un
contenu à l'éditeur d'un réseau social
ou cas facebook ou twitter le réseau
avait une heure pour supprimer le
contenu et on a craint qu'il y ait une
espèce d'automaticité pour la
suppression sans contre le juge est
finalement une censure qui pourrait être
orchestrée par la loi vient lui limité n
ça passe par énormément de choses
d'abord il faut savoir que sur les
réseaux sociaux on a des systèmes de
notification et c'est obligatoire les
réseaux sociaux doivent mettre à
disposition des internautes et ça c'est
déjà cette vieille loi française de 2004
qu'il imposait donc doivent mettre à
disposition des internautes les moyens
qui permettent de notifier les coûts
veineux est par ailleurs aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux investissent énormément
notamment dans l'algorithme pour essayer
de détecter en amont
ce qui pourrait relever d'un contenu
haineux et l'idée ce serait
effectivement de responsabiliser les
plateformes mais de les responsabilités
de les responsabiliser pour les uns les
inciter à poursuivre ses investissements
justement donner du goût du pouvoir aux
gaffes à de dire si oui ou non si oui ou
non le contenu est publiable
ça vous semble fiable mélanger des gens
privés avec des décisions juridiques
il n'y a pas un risque est là justement
en maintenant en développement une
algorithmique et en maintenant une fille
née à la fois un contrôle humain est
effectivement tout ça sous contrôle du
juge puisque c'est c'est le juge qui
doit demeurer qui est garant de la
liberté d'expression pour revenir sur
sur la loi avia désole on a des petites
coupures internet je croyais que vous
aviez terminé votre intérêt et votre
intervention au sujet de cette question
mais juste pour revenir sur la loi vient
en quoi est ce qu'elle aurait pu
empêcher le drame de conflans sainte
honorine or on le rappelle un le compte
twitter du terroriste aurait été
signalée le 10 octobre soit six jours
avant l'entente avant l'attentât
parce que les lois vient proposer deux
dispositifs automatiques qui était d'une
part que dans l'hypothèse où un contenu
était signalée par l'administration
le réseau social avait une heure pour le
supprimer
sous peine d'une dame d'une amende de
250 mille euros et un deuxième
dispositif qui était lui de 24 heures en
cas de signalement d'un contenus odieux
par un contenu manifestement illicite
par un internaute
donc cette ces sanctions et ses délais
excessivement stricts aurait pu
effectivement imposer enfin les réseaux
sociaux aurait pu s'imposer
le retrait automatique pour éviter les
sanctions notamment financières
et là-dessus effectivement à la loi
vient aurait pu ou pas d'ailleurs être
efficaces mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le biais de ces points vient de
moeurs qui est un risque pour la liberté
d'expression peut trouver un équilibre
entre les deux justement peut revenir la
sueur
table cette loi vient avec avec ce qui
s'est passé à conflans sainte honorine
beaucoup d'observateurs il voit une
récupération politique
votre réaction c'est pas sûr qu'il
puisse revenir c'est pas une loi c'est
loin qui existe déjà c'est un système
qui existe déjà notamment en allemagne
puisque depuis 2010 est on a une loi qui
s'appelle l' annexe des gays qui est à
peu près qui est à peu près fait sur sur
le modèle de la loi 1 vient donc avec
des procédures de traitement automatique
des signalements qui peuvent être
réalisés sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense pas qu'en france la france
seule fasse revenir la loi via sur sur
le terrain en revanche les travaux qui
sont engagés notamment les travaux qui
sont engagées au niveau européen vont
certainement aboutir à des règles de
régulation une obligation de bien neuf 9
d'un certain nombre de procédures de
sécurité
ça sera plutôt à un niveau européen dans
lequel d'une évolution de la
réglementation européenne
merci marc soulas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes spécialisé
avocate spécialisée de la propriété
intellectuelle et du droit de data
notamment